from a village house in the hills of
nagorno-karabakh to a temporary
unfurnished flat an hour outside Yerevan
Annie Gregorian her husband atashes
Medallion and their children must start
over
everything they owned they left behind
in the rush to leave
we never imagined leaving we thought
maybe they will give a small part of the
land and it will calm down or that they
would negotiate and come to some
agreement but we didn't think that
karaba would be left with no Armenians
Azerbaijan says the ethnic Armenian
security is guaranteed but no one here
believed them tens of thousands of
people have died fighting for and
against nagorno-karabakh in the last 30
years
the men of Our Generation cannot live
with the azerbaijanis maybe the women
could live somehow or the elderly when I
talked to my grandfather he says well we
were living together back then maybe
their generation can somehow deal with
it and live together but our generation
cannot we saw so many wars how can a
person who bury the Sun and didn't even
see him adopt to living with them
the family is staying with relatives
until they find furniture but the flat
is only theirs for two months loaned
until the owners return after years
abroad
I think it might be possible to go back
in a few years no I hope it might my
husband has big hopes he's saying yes we
will go back but I don't know
for now though Annie is worried about
school for her son and how they make
ends meet
the Armenian government says it's
coordinating with a groups and Charities
to help provide accommodation financial
support medical and psychological Aid to
help families rebuild their lives but
it's a significant challenge for a poor
country that's just seen its population
increase by four percent in less than a
week
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Yerevan
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera